It was really warm over the last weekend.
I guess the weather is going crazy.
The temperature suddenly rose up to 12 degrees Celsius,...
...and then today, it went down to minus seven.
I remember that this summer, there was a typhoon called Nari that hit Jeju Island...
...and it left a lot of damage.
Korea has a really heavy rainy season.
Compared to past years, how have the seasons in Korea changed?
Let me recall.
Well, there are usually four distinct seasons in Korea...
...and it was easy to tell when a certain season begins and ends.
But lately, we don't seem to have spring and fall...
...my two favorite seasons!
The weather is either extremely hot and humid or cold.
I'm afraid to say it, but it all has to do with climate change.
Climate change is one of the most critical global challenges of our time...
...and it's time for us to take action.
As we mentioned, not just in Korea,...
...but other recent events around the world have emphatically demonstrated our growing vulnerability to climate change.
Right, we really need to inform people about the potential changes in our weather.
Tragic natural disasters like wildfires, typhoons, cyclones, and avalanches...
...they all have to do with change in climate and global warming.
Starting today, we have to look for what we can do to fight climate change...
...which is the greatest environmental challenge facing the world today.